PYONGYANG HAS LAUNCHED A 2ND
MISSILE TEST IN LESS THAN A
WEEK.
JUST AFTER 7 AM LOCAL TIME
THURSDAY, 2 SHORT RANGE
BALLISTIC MISSILES WERE
LAUNCHED FROM NORTH KOREA'S
EAST COAST.
TRAVELED 450 KILOMETERS BEFORE
LANDING IN THE SEA.
CNN'S PAULA HANCOCKS, LIVE FROM
SEOUL THIS HOUR.
, POLISHER START WITH WHAT WAS
FIRED THESE NEW AND IMPROVED
MISSILES, AS A SIGN WITH THE
WEAPONS TEST OVER THE WEEKEND?
.
>> WELL JOHN, LET'S WHEN
EXPERTS ARE LOOKING AT RIGHT
NOW OBVIOUSLY WAITING FOR ANY
IMAGES THAT WE HAVE MISSED A
RUN MEDIA.
THEY ARE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
IF THIS IS A SHORT RANGE
MISSILE THAT HAVE BEEN TESTED,
ONE WON ABOUT 20 KILOMETERS
WHEN ABOUT 30 KILOMETERS.
THEY ARE WITHIN THE SHORT RANGE
MISSILE SPHERE.
BUT THEY ARE BALLISTIC MISSILES
WHICH MEANS THEY'RE AGAINST
U.S. SECURITY COUNCIL
RESOLUTIONS, THEY DO VIOLATE
THE RULES AGAINST NORTH KOREA.
SO CERTAINLY THIS IS A STEP UP
FROM WHAT WE SAW LAST WEEKEND,
WHEN THAT WAS A WEAPONS TEST,
IT WASN'T A BANNED WEAPONS
TEST.
AT THAT POINT, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION REALLY
DOWNPLAYED IT, SAYING THAT THEY
DIDN'T SEE IT AS CHANGING THE
DYNAMICS TOO MUCH.
IT WAS REALLY AT THE LOW END OF
THE SPECTRUM OF WHAT NORTH
KOREA COULD DO.
SO REALLY, WHAT WE ARE SEEING
HERE IS A STEP UP FROM NORTH
KOREA, THEY ARE NOW GOING TO
THE SHORT RANGE BALLISTIC
MISSILES, WHICH THEY KNOW THAT
THE U.S. WILL HAVE TO REACT TO
IN SOME WAY.
BEFORE ANY REACTION FROM THE
REGION, JAPAN'S PRIME MINISTER
SAYS THAT THIS IS THE THREAT
FOR THE PEACE AND SECURITY OF
JAPAN.
HERE IN SOUTH KOREA THEY'VE HAD
A NATIONAL SECURITY COUNCIL
MEETING, THEY CALLED US OF DEEP
CONCERN.
BOTH OF THESE COUNTRIES HAVE
INCREASED THEIR SURVEILLANCE ON
THE AREA AS WELL.
ALSO, WHAT IT HAS DONE IS THAT
IT HAS ENSURED THAT IT'S FRONT
AND CENTER, ONCE AGAIN JUST
AHEAD OF THE U.S. PRESIDENT
BIDEN'S PRESS CONFERENCE ON
THURSDAY, JOHN.
>> OKAY, SO IF WE'RE BACK TO
BUSINESS AS USUAL AS IT APPEARS
TO BE.
IT LOOKS LIKE NORTH KOREA HAS
PLENTY OF ROOM TO ESCALATE
THESE WEAPONS TEST, THAT I
GUESS IS THE BIG FEAR THAT IF
THE BIDEN MINISTRATION DOESN'T
RESPOND IN A WAY THAT PYONGYANG
IS HAPPY WITH, THEN WE WILL SEE
MORE WEAPONS TEST ESCALATING UP
TO SOME KIND OF NUCLEAR TEST AS
THE ULTIMATE OCTAVE DEFINED BY
THE NORTH.
IS THAT SORT OF THE TRAJECTORY
THAT WE'RE ON RIGHT NOW?
>> IT'S CERTAINLY SOMETHING WE
HAVE SEEN SO MANY TIMES IN THE
PAST, THIS IS OFTEN CYCLICAL.
WE KNOW THE U.S. HAS REACHED
OUT TO NORTH KOREA, WE KNOW THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION SECRETARY
BLINKEN AND JUST LAST WEEK IN
THE REGION ADMITTED THAT THEY
HAVE BEEN REACHING OUT SINCE
MID FEBRUARY, BUT I HEARD
NOTHING BACK.
WE KNOW THAT THROUGH STATE RUN
MEDIA IN NORTH KOREA SAYS
THERE'S NO POINT TALKING UNTIL
THE U.S. CHANGES ITS HOSTILE
POLICY.
WE EVEN HAD KIM JOHN'S SISTER
WHO IS OFTEN BROUGHT OVER THE
MORE STERN WORDS AGAINST SOUTH
KOREA AND THE U.S., SAYING THAT
THE U.S. SHOULD EFFECTIVELY
TREAD VERY CAREFULLY.
SO AT THIS, POINT IT DOES
APPEAR AS WE ARE ON ONE OF
THESE CYCLES WHERE WE COULD SEE
INCREASING SEVERITY OF THESE
LAUNCHES AND THESE MISSILE
TESTS.
IT'S NOT CLEAR AT THIS POINT
WHAT'S NORTH KOREA'S INTENTIONS
ARE THOUGH, IT'S SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT IN THE FACT THAT THIS
TIME AROUND THE U.S. DOES
APPEAR TO BE WILLING TO TALK.
WE ARE STILL WAITING FOR THAT
NORTH KOREA POLICY REVIEW FROM
THE NEW BIDEN ADMINISTRATION,
IT'S EVERY INCOMING U.S.
ADMINISTRATION DOES.
IT REVIEWS WITH THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION DID, BUT AT THIS
POINT MOST PEOPLE WERE WAITING
FOR THAT BUT NORTH KOREA
CLEARLY COULDN'T WAIT.
>> YOU KNOW, THE WHITE HOUSE
SAYS I